rolling cheers Cheers
yay friendship friends soon like
thinking this cuz it's me on the
Facebook by far they must awkward drink
to drink in the public eye but if
someone you know starts a conversation
that you want to avoid just go home
sapphire oh oh my god girl yeah guys I'm
here with Elliott Morgan hi everybody
we're here shooting a video Elliott has
and will continue to be fantastic yeah
Thank You Elliott is on this week's
episode of not too deep the podcast go
check it out on soundcloud or iTunes and
while he's here I thought we'd shoot a
challenge video today we're shooting the
Jenga challenge awesome
have you played Jenga before I have ok
listen that's the first step went on
Facebook and we asked you guys for
truths and dares and wrote them on some
of the Jenga tile oh cool yeah is
happening here I had a challenge video
all right you said at the beginning that
I didn't believe you until just now can
we rewind and play him thing oh cool
sure I got a flashback of Elliott as a
six year old kid like a skateboard oh
come on dad thank you yes it's best as
we piled a tile if it has a
truth-or-dare on it you have to do said
truth or dare okay and if you were the
one that ends up knocking down the Jenga
tower your consequence is that you have
to do the whip okay um I'm gonna be a
very gracious host and allow you to go
first oh thank you so I can I can just
go yep you can pick any time you want
some of them don't have truth or dares
on them so you get a oh my god yeah what
about lose it on the person thanks Raj
and everybody it's a 40-second b oh
hello hello friend here we go
what does it have something it has
nothing sir oh there we go okay this is
where you touch and see you guys once
yeah
you ever play with some who doesn't let
you touch blanks me oh yeah where it's
like the first one you touch you have to
go for real Jenga purists yeah I hate it
no score into the Jenga Scientology and
they told me as well the Airbender
they're building the Jenga Scientology
building it's beautiful yeah this is the
best game so far yeah this is
captivating I was gonna make yes yes yes
yes yes and nothing haha
I hope there's just no truth is just
plain straight Jenga hey buddy hey buddy
look I was a good and nothing yes yes Oh
goddamn it
ah what is it a worst drunk story this
one of them um I are juice I don't I was
a backpacking through Europe with a
boyfriend after graduated college we
went to Running of the Bulls and we
started drinking box wine at 8 a.m. in a
park and we ended up having to take a
train I blacked out and then like wreak
a m-- to consciousness on the train like
asleep by the window and he told me that
I just kept running into soccer games
trying to play with all the guys there
and when they wouldn't let me play I
just started sobbing crying in the
middle of all these Spanish men playing
soccer like for real and I was like let
me play I'm not just American here it
didn't work out between you two or no
we're not together anymore are you gonna
tell yours too well it's not nearly as
good as that basically there's a game
there it's called the greatest cocktail
party or the biggest cocktail party in
the world it's Georgia versus Florida
and it happens in Jacksonville every
year and I was in college and my wife
and I went to see it and the Gators won
and that's our team and so I decided to
celebrate by giving as drunk as humanly
possible and I had these things called
not Long Island iced teas but they're
the blue kind and so I bought one and
then I have one and I drank it
immediately and then I bought another
for my wife and she said no thank you
and sorry I said I would drink this in
your honor and then I went into a porta
potti to relieve myself fell backwards
out of the Porta Potty mid P Oh like
lean back like the door was locked and
the door flung open and I flew into the
world
everybody was just like huge hmm I don't
know they actually spoke in slow motion
it was also Halloween which just added
to the man yeah and there's I remember
my wife was calling a taxi and a group
of like girls dresses like 18 Playboy
Bunnies walked by gun oh like that and I
remember digging Oh Grover's and then uh
that I just specifically remember the
cab driver being like don't throw up in
my car and I remember think I can't
throw him a car and then I did I knew
that I couldn't do it in his car because
that's very rude so I made sure it
leaned it all on myself and then I got
it back to the hotel room and then threw
up all my and then died the next day
and I came back to fight I didn't join
any soccer games Wow that good that yeah
that's what Heaven's like it is yeah
gaggle of Playboy Bunnies going oh oh um
truth
have you ever slapped someone no I've
never I've never slapped someone because
i i i can't even slap people like if
it's in a script i don't have to like
slap someone very intimate yeah it also
feels like very violent there's some
reason and something like very like
concentrated and violent but I have
gotten slapped by a guy playing ultimate
frisbee when I was in high school once
he was in high school and it was our
team versus his team in this Ultimate
Frisbee and somehow it was like already
really really competitive before we
haven't started and I was getting up in
this guy's face like I was like I'm a
girl I would improve that okay do
anything you can't do anything in me I
know at a Latin convention and he was
like trying to like keep the frisbee
away from me and then just slap me
across the face and I was like oh and no
one saw expect like in the back your
mind is you expect like sirens to go up
expected later like a vlog like a record
player scratch happens all their music
stops and everyone addresses that guy
and no one did and nothing I'm doing
great guys killin it which is good cuz I
don't have any stories
I don't really need to do this Oh story
base all right I'm gonna start taking
some risks here yeah I do it there you
go that's good oh wow
ha ha and nothing killing it all right
my hands are shaking now love you all
Jesus ah mother no nothing
damn it all right ha
dare hold a dog treat in your mouth for
10 seconds that's easy you know when I
used to work in an animal hospital
I would try all the dog treats we're
just going to turn off I'm gonna turn
every dare you have into a truth it's
from true story yeah I would try every
single one of them cuz they smell so
good some of them smell good and I would
just get curious like what are these
dogs like you know how they make the
treats like look like daisies yeah and
make it yeah I mean I was like are the
dogs like are we fooling ourselves are
we actually fooling the dog so he's
actually he tastes like bacon and it
turns out we're just fooling ourselves
but yeah we're already
it's almost weirder that you're just
holding it cuz your saliva is like
building your mouth we'll go an
involuntary reflex
like that's grosser than just eating it
what do you do fry you're up oh oh Jesus
oh my god oh my god you know what okay
Dan it's a thing as a Bansal
Oh God nope why Oh what what the actual
Oh dares sing the alphabet backwards
that's such an easy dare yeah it totally
is z Y X W B mm-hmm
those are letters T as R cube hmm B o ml
huh lovely there hey Jay are you saying
I it's getting sadder the closer you get
to the end G f DC be a there goes a
minute of the entire video so sorry guys
buy that song on iTunes
okay you know what we'll listen oh how
dare you how this is it
this is you're done the world it was fun
it's good yeah they're shaking time I
don't know I don't know I'm gonna cover
my drink just oh no no god I feel like I
can finally breathe oh good
where something does the whip and the
Naenae someone like to sing I got a beat
for it okay here we go uh any B does it
matter any peep
thank you yeah there you go that was the
Jenga challenge Elliot thank you for um
you know just delighting me with all of
your stories yeah no thank you for
having me and I'm gonna regret saying
all those things that I said yeah I'm
sure your wife is really excited she's
so that's Mandy great oh the worst story
you told the worst and you didn't have
to you yes like willing to volunteer it
was her question good call Elliot yeah
make sure you guys go listen to the full
podcast with Elliot on SoundCloud or
iTunes and go over and check out
Elliot's channel because there are funny
funny things there and are there for
anyone that's local any shows they can
see you at if you're around I'm doing
the Burbank Comedy Festival because you
can come by drop in say hi it's not a
big deal and you can go to um Elliott
Morgan special comm for news on my
comedy special yeah I know I didn't
quote to the comedy special and that's
no reason a drama
look I seem like is it yeah it's it's
actually a documentary Elliott Morgan
everybody I see you next time I don't
know this your stance on animals now you
still like you don't hate them talk yeah
you got to get rid of them they are
everywhere a threat don't like small
ones are everywhere the big ones are
like hiding but still they're creeping
in the shadows